conteur de génie présente dans son
nouveau spectacle cet allumé que le
langage fait vivre pour ce faire il a
écrit cette monologues et s'est adjoint
les services de cette metteur en scène
différents il sera entre autres le 24
avril à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt
voici pépito matéo dans le kiosque c'est
un comble cette coupe
et ne m'accroche pas crola
tu mets crassous irait comme à
l'acoustique est au grossissement de
plumes et ans que je te dire jouer tous
nos jeux fois c'était croûte
tu m'as prouve rescue niant comme touche
la zone avec mes malemort façon n'est
pas ta pâte qui monte booster et mon art
carapace de capharnaüm
ce sont des personnages qui ont des
problèmes de langage que moins tourner
un petit peu en rond moi je suis un peu
obsédé par les chiffres et au départ je
voulais travailler sur les fous
littéraires les fous littéraires c'est
un peu les gens qui qui écrivent sans
nuance est dit en eux-mêmes ou en ayant
une démarche un petit peu il faut pas
partie de courant ils ont pas fait d'eux
les circuits normaux c'est un peu l'art
brut en littérature et je me suis
intéressé beaucoup à ça j'ai lu beaucoup
de choses je les fous littéraires et je
me disais que c'était intéressant de
travailler sur le langage moi je suis
content heures c'est pour ça que je suis
à côté de l'arbre à palabre je me suis
dit au fond est ce qu'il y aurait pas
des gens aujourd'hui dans le monde qui
parle autour de nous qui parle pour
tenir debout comme ces fous littéraires
qui essayent de terre de boue en
écrivant des histoires et donc j'ai
répertorié un certain nombre de
silhouettes dans ce qui m'entoure des
gens qui me hante des sdf qui parle tout
seul chauffeur de taxi qui m'a raconté
sa guerre tout en me parlant de la
circulation des gens qui parlent et qui
parle un peu dans leur bulle bien alors
tout le monde est là 1 on se détend on
respire alors les trapèzes 1
alors c'est important que vous ayez fait
la démarche comme on dit c'est le
premier pas qui compte alors moi je veux
pas vous raconter d'histoires je
m'appelle france 53 ans ça veut dire de
l'expérience
alors la première chose que j'ai envie
de vous dire c'est avoir l'oeil 1
ça c'est important c'est un peu le b à
ba alors votre pièce il va falloir
détecté de visu si elle est bancal où le
niveau 1 et si elle n'est pas morgane
banco voilà je crois que j'ai fait à
mademoiselle c'est un truc pour détendre
l'atmosphère bien alors on reprend on se
détend on respire on y croit les
trapèzes alors primo du coup je me suis
mis à systématiser l'écriture en sept
mois je suis un petit peu intéressés par
ces questions un peu oulipienne de
l'écriture soit j'invente mais histoire
de tout de toutes pièces dans
l'imaginaire
soit je pars du réel je vais interroger
les urgences à l'hôpital des infirmières
et je travaille sur le réel
soit je me donne des contraintes et là
je m'étais dit je vais me donner cette
contrainte d'écriture alors sept
personnages 7 monologue sept problèmes
de langage cette résonance avec la
mythologie ou la littérature sept péchés
capitaux etc
j'ai décidé de pousser le bouchon en
donnant ses sept monologue à cette
metteur en scène différents qui
acceptent de jouer le jeu
parce que je leur donnais à chacun cette
contrainte de mise en scène dont une
chorégraphe je voulais qu'il y ait au
moins un ou une chorégraphe que ce soit
pas que des metteurs en scène et je
voulais y ait au moins une femme
il y en a 2 ou le seuil et j'ai mis la
moelle argent pièce là pour la machine
la vella la machine là peu plus blanc
l'aca coton synthétique rose c'est ça sa
trempe à monet à partir de ce moment là
je leur ai donné les clés en leur disant
voilà moi je porte des monologues je
peux faire ce que vous voulez emmenez
moi dans votre univers à vous et donc
chacun m'a embarqué dans dans sa façon
de travailler à texte un certain nombre
mon travail c'est travaille justement
sur le texte la manière de le dire le
jeu le corps
la voix et puis d'autres m'ont mis dans
une image avec des vins écran avec la
certaine éclairage des choses comme ça
qu'ils m'ont amené presque vers le
cinéma quoi et donc il a fallu ensuite
coudre c7 monologue pour créer quelque
chose qui soit à la fois il n'y a pas
une histoire qui les relie je suis moi
lui l'histoire qui les relie mais à la
fois une évolution dans le propos est
dans comment les monologues se répondent
de l'un à l'autre ses marques et la
mettais pièce l'appareil l'appareil
l'appareil la la ceni mais ça marche pas
les pièges jeunes mais les les jeunes
pièces jaunes ça m'a rejeté la néo
cocotte qui dit qu'il vaut rien ne vaut
rien toi même est pas passé de l'argent
sale pourquoi tu me le rend la doua est
là la machine
la machine du monde qui marchent tête en
bas à l'envers bouffe saloperie de
mobilier un marche pas la machine folle
numéro s'est jamais numéro un c'est pas
quelqu'un qui s'en occupe alors papa
dabis l'avait salle au prisunic ton fric
tu me laisses m'accroche je pus 5 vicié
patent sentir la vie que je m'énerve pas
trop de gueuler de police circulait rien
rien à voir ça donne quand même un
panorama d'où on ne sort pas tout à fait
indemne parce que ça nous emmène quand
même dans des personnes avec des
personnages qui sont un peu à la limite
de la pas de la folie mais de la
marginalité ils sont ils sont tous quand
même un peu en marge de la société quoi
là on s'approche du théâtre parce que ce
sont des monologues
donc ce sont des personnages qui nous
parle mais on s'aperçoit petit à petit
qu'ils parlent dans une bulle
c'est un malentendu s'il nous parle donc
cette relation est étrange
mais tu vieux saloir - compte mal sûrs
tu viens saloir je suis vitrine d'une
horreur de jument de cuines enfants
tissage les vôtres mais pour chiasse et
pourtant j'ai vu leur flair oui j'ai
déliré leur flair mais eux montent en
force des extraits dans mon association
isolante un but je te faire rissoler de
moi dans mon état l'âge mais microbes
les bêtises
tout vient chez gan géré tout un flan je
soustrais d'humilité malavialle leamy
timide
évitez vous que jeu complet pour que dan
je n'osais même pas fendre la parabole
en public a clos ce que j'allais une
prothèse du langage y héréditaire qui
fait eric aurait tout monstre
dès que je voudrais la bouche
maintenant un autre sujet la rédaction
poésie féerie imaginaire voilà en
quelques mots
l'univers magique et marionnettes
proposé par la grange de la tramblais
jusqu'au 7 avril à l'initiative de la
ville de bois d'arcy
le 4e festival de marionnettes est
l'occasion pour petits et grands de
découvrir des techniques de manipulation
original une programmation qui se veut
diversifiée parce que l'art de la
marionnette déjà c'est un art qui n'est
pas spécifique à un style de
marionnettes il règne dans le monde
entier et des traditions différentes
avec des manipulations différentes que
soient les théâtres le fameux guignol
avec manette à genk seulement et a links
mettre sur table
sa marque se développe beaucoup parce
que voilà antoine abdallah de la marina
di sita l'objet voilà donc en créer
d'imaginer au niveau 2 des gens du
public et autant plus qu un public peu à
du théâtre et opéra objets comédie
musicale autant de genre présentée au
festival entre diversité des techniques
et diversité des cultures
les marionnettes invite au voyage les
gens pensent souvent les marionnettes
sont des marionnettes à fils ou
éventuellement à main alors qu'en fait
si la quantité de techniques et si en
plus de ça on fait un petit peu le tour
du monde
ce qu'on propose là c'est la diversité
qui devient tout à fait intéressante
diversité des techniques et diversité
aussi des cultures c'est le voyage
c'est l'insee c'est tout cela à la fois
véritable spectacle vivant les
marionnettes transmettent toutes sortes
d'émotions qui font le bonheur du public
ça rappelle l'enfance à la fois c'est
pour les petits pour les grands parce
qu'on fait passer des messages
extraordinaire à travers les
marionnettes les deux prochains
spectacles à voir en famille auront lieu
samedi 6 et dimanche 7 avril
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de vider le sac de l'aspirateur le 12
avril madiot sur un concert au scarabée
à la verrière bénabar sera quant à lui
le 13 avril à la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux l'extraordinaire
comédienne danseuse et marionnettiste il
cache online sera le 14 avril à la
merise attrape avec la vieille et la
bête et audrey bonnet et stanislas
nordey interpréteront leur clôture de
l'amour du 16 au 26 avril au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de n'être que
vous pouvez retrouver sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affiche à cette semaine
sur le www.kia.ca qui point fr vous
pouvez gagner jusqu'au 8 avril 5 x 2
places pour comme le chien de françois
chaffin à la ferme devait les bars alors
bon spectacle à tous et à bientôt